Oh
this is Dominic Dominic works at a
5-star restaurant called the pixel
palace they're some of videogames most
popular characters come in to have a
drink sometimes they share stories and
even secrets for as we all know what the
bartender hears is confidential isn't it
so I'm sitting there tending bar what in
walks someone you don't hear that much
about Princess Daisy now I guess you do
see her a lot was no doubt about that
but nobody well he knows that much about
her she's a spitting image of Princess
Peach but nobody knows all my good
friends is she a sister she some Soviets
talk I mean nobody knows so she sits
down at the ball am I gonna drink and I
say Oh mrs. D how's it going she says oh
what can't complain just got done doing
some go-carts
oh he's a good time he says you know
it's very hard to go cold in a dress I
don't know maybe people know that
I just say very candidly - I see sohow
speech she says all right
and I asked very candidly um what is she
to you exactly I mean are you a and are
you her sister
Jesus clone say Oh
oh yeah I'm a clue her idea actually
princess peach's I'm actually one of
many clothes
you remember Pauline from Donkey Kong
yeah that's just a test run you don't
see her around that lunch anymore do you
and also what happened to her and she
said well they gotta feed the goombas
and koopa something don't they listen
Jesus you mean they killed her and she
said yeah but she was a bit though
anyway did that her the important thing
is what happened with me
you see I was a decoy for a while she
want a little bit of extra security so I
used to be a double you know I go in
wear the pink dress and everything but
after a while people stop to catch on so
forgive me a yellow dress gave me my own
Kingdom and I'm so Amer for backup so
back up for long she says well Paige is
very protective of her Kingdom so in
case anything was to happen to it she
has this other Kingdom on standby just
in case she doesn't want anyone to think
it's like a superpower anything so she
made up the story about this alien
kidnapping me and you know how you have
to save me and get all the good stuff I
said your kingdoms a superpower and she
said oh yeah so the Mushroom Kingdom
unbelievable power the weapons they have
indescribable not so what woman she's
getting kidnapped like every other
minute she
Nanna soft show you see every time she
gets kidnapped they have to up security
every single time so Willy
they're one of those unstoppable nations
in the world she said really what grown
woman in royalty could get kidnapped
that many times you think a plumber
overalls is saving all the time so he
isn't she says no no no they just put on
a little show trying to act like he's
Almighty you know she gets in the cage
and you know she begs him a cake or
betel cheese stuff but honestly the
Mushroom Kingdom is one of the most
powerful forces in the world not so
wonderful you're telling me that airhead
the pink dress is actually some sort of
super genius she goes oh yeah
the good at doesn't it everybody thinks
she just Suzie homemaker Oh fight people
off with a frying pan
just swing a dress out of battle work
seriously though she knows ninjutsu she
can break your nut just by look at my
chat the cutesy princess thing yeah it's
all an act
not so but that can't be possible you
got the king he's the guy in charge she
says have you ever seen the king of the
Mushroom Kingdom
No
exist she made a mother just to make
everybody think that she's the sweet
little princess stuck in a tower with
nobody around to protect her all right
let me just get this straight
Princess Peach is one of the smartest
people in the world you're a clone the
Mushroom Kingdom is one of the most
powerful military forces in the world
you have your own Kingdom that's a
growing power and she says yeah that's a
great act isn't it she's even get Mario
convinced that she has some sauce
Stockholm Syndrome she likes being
locked in a cage and stuff it's
wonderful not so okay well what's the
master plan why does she want so much
power
she says Oh total global takeover on the
end of 2030 everybody's gotta look like
a shrimp you know the term Hitler used
these are told are gonna be like RPG
youths everyone would look the same and
thus everybody will agree nobody will be
fighting and there'll be no one's a
brilliant plan I'll set the star your
Bullock or tomato tomahto it's all the
same thing she says and also what's to
stop me from telling everybody about
this she looks me the audience's who'd
believe you
can water on that the act it's just too
good nobody believed me if I said she
was one of the smartest woman in the
world if not the smartest she just gave
us shrug finished her drink it started
out but before she went uh sat on my
just tell me one thing
you're really gonna take over the world
what's the plan and what part do you
play
she says you know we just made a
partnership with GLaDOS you know that
new cellphone that everybody has in
Kaplan without not said oh yeah even I
got one of those why she gave her the
wink and said just remember I said that
that means
see a wall strange things as a bartender
so you're more strange things at the
pixel Palace so I'll see a lot of
strange things as a bottom pixel paths
ain't no sweat
you